[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
were going to be discussing Severus
Snape filius Flitwick and an interesting
incident where Flitwick was on the
receiving end of one a Snape stunning
spells and this was before he killed
Dumbledore the incident of course
occurred on the night the dark mark was
cast upon the Astronomy tower
the following excerpt from a text
depicts the scene outside Snape's office
yes whispered Hermione her eyes
sparkling with tears with Luna it was
nearly midnight when Professor Flitwick
Kim's sprinting down into the dungeons
he was shouting about Death Eaters in
the castle I don't think he really
registered that Luna and I were there at
all he just burst his way in his name's
office and we heard him saying sniper to
go back with him and help and then we
heard a loud thump and Snape came
hurtling out of the room and he saw us
and and I was so stupid Harry said
Hermione in a high-pitched whisper he
said Professor Flitwick had collapsed
and we should go and take care of him
while he while he went to help fight the
Death Eaters we went into his office to
see if we could help Professor Flitwick
and found him unconscious on the floor
and oh it's so obvious now Snape must
have stupefied Flitwick but we didn't
realize Harry we didn't realize we just
let Snape go this whole scenario was a
bit confusing because Snape and Flitwick
were behind closed doors no Death Eaters
were present I'm sure maybe he was
trying to protect Flitwick by keeping
him away from a potential fight but if
that was the case why wouldn't he have
stunned Hermione or Luna some have
speculated that Snape did it because he
knew that he would need to fulfill his
promise to Dumbledore he knew that on
that fateful night he would need to end
Umble doors life had Snape not stupefied
Flitwick
then he would have run the risk of
Flitwick following him to the Astronomy
Tower
which would have made his job of killing
Dumbledore much more difficult Snape
wasn't going to tell Flitwick about the
plan and there's absolutely no way that
he would be able to rationalize what was
about to happen
however the issue with this is that at
this point in time Snape didn't actually
know whether or not Dumbledore had
returned Hogwarts
so he wasn't actually going to the
Astronomy tower to kill Dumbledore
he was simply going there because a dark
mark had appeared all Snape knew at this
stage was that something was going on
the mark of the Death Eaters was above
the school and that's probably never a
good thing
at this stage Snape's loyalties were
still very much unclear to many and both
sides thought to the hen a lie when the
dark mark appeared Snape knew that he
would need to go and investigate
however when Flitwick appeared in front
of him who presented him with a problem
how would Snape possibly be able to go
and see the Death Eaters Flitwick tagged
along with him it would be a weird
awkward situation
Western it wouldn't be able to tack
either side if he attacked the Death
Eaters to prove loyalty to flip WIC he
would be blowing his cover and if he
attacked Flitwick he would be attacking
a genuine ally so to answer the question
posed at the beginning of the video
Snape did what was best for everyone
standing flatwood caused him no
permanent damage and potentially saved
his life additionally Snape was able to
investigate what was going on without
risk for blowing his cover
why sniper decided to let Hermione and
Luna go without selling them is unclear
but I would imagine that he thought
tending to Flitwick
would keep them occupied for long enough
additionally things get a bit messy when
you start firing stupefy left and right
at your allies it can't feel good to get
hit with a stupefying spell but it
probably beats getting hit with Avada
Kedavra and that's it for this video if
you enjoyed the content please remember
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]